is the footage that we're told is
supposed to be a big Scandal for Rhonda
sandton I don't think the NRA is quite
the boogeyman the Democrats think it is
do we hit him on guns or just everyone
who cares about guns is going to vote
for me is there any issue upon which you
disagree with President Trump frame it
in a way that's not going to piss off
all his voters so what I do is I do what
I think is right I support his agenda in
terms of what he's been able to do if I
have a disagreement I talk to him in
private that is uh that's a major
Scandal I can't even believe this and as
a formerly a rod of Santa supporter I'm
going to have to start rethinking my
support from because apparently Ron
DeSantis engaged in political strategy
before a debate he was with his team and
they were strategizing how to best
answer questions and how he should
present himself I mean I'm speechless
I'm stunned no politician in the history
of politics has ever done this this he's
the first one to ever do something as
horrific as this apparently he has a
he's a team of people around him to work
on strategy with him unbelievable